Good morning John!
A couple of weeks ago Tumblr changed how it
displays reblogs and I did not like this because
it was change and I was frustrated.
And then last week I went to Yellowstone National
Park, potentially the coolest place on earth.
It was the first national park ever created
and it's one of the most dangerous things
on the planet.
Not, like, to individuals travelling in the
park, though that can be dangerous too, I
mean to the whole world, really.
Part of the reason Yellowstone is so interesting
is that it is a very, very big volcano. 3
times in the last 2 million years the Yellowstone
supervolcano has erupted, spewing out tens
or even hundreds of cubic miles of debris
affecting global weather patterns and laying
ash down as far away as Texas.
Now, this isn't gonna happen again anytime
soon, but it will happen again someday, and
when it happens, the park will basically be
gone.
But the remarkable thing is
that it happened 600,000 years ago, and as
you travel the park, you drive over the rim
of the caldera formed in that eruption.
And other than that, the desolation that eruption
caused is pretty much invisible.
Life just rushed back in to fill the void
created by that massive event.
The ground is a thing that doesn't move.
If you're grounded, you're like a rock.
People change.
The things we make change, but the land remains
the same.
And yet it doesn't.
In Yellowstone, more than anywhere, places
do not stay the same.
Geysers turn on and off.
New springs eat through the ground.
As the water cools, crystals are deposited,
building into giant mounds.
And the ground itself rises and falls in ripples
and domes across the land as hot gas and magma
surges beneath the surface.
Everything constant is a lie, and my life
continues to remind me of that.
We want stability, but we can't have it.
And that's both sad and wonderful.
Now, we apply false stability to Yellowstone.
It's most famous landmark, of course, is Old
Faithful, geyser that blasts every 70 minutes
or so with remarkable regularity, but Old
Faithful will one day cheat on us and everyone
knows that.
Some day all of the benches and lodges we
built around it will just be a semi-circle
around a bunch of dry rocks.
Here's New Blue Spring, now dormant and white.
And this is Constant Geyser, so named because
it never stops spurting, until it did.
But Yellowstone has broken no contract with
us.
It makes no pretense of stability.
It's honest, in a way that the rest of the
Earth and even life isn't.
An honesty that reminds me that the inevitability
of change, though it terrifies me, it also
excites me.
That incurable illness that always makes me
want to know what's next; to see the future,
the future where things, are not like they
are today.
The future that will allow me to look back
and miss what once was.
That will scrub my present day of the dinginess,
of the crud, until I only remember the brilliant
sparkles, and the deepest gashes.
We're all standing on that cliff, beyond which
there is nothing, until there is.
And we always believe that it will be there,
especially those of us that have been so rarely
burned, until someday it isn't there and your
life has changed; your world has changed.
And there's nothing you can do to get it back
again.
Yellowstone doesn't lie to me.
Yellowstone reminds me that even something
as constant as the ground beneath my feet
could just one day fly into the air and land
in Texas.
And so maybe the way my reblogs look on Tumblr
isn't the thing I should be worrying about.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
We've been in a really long traffic jam.
We don't know what we've been in a traffic
jam for.
And when this minivan moves, we will find
out.
What is it?
Katherine: It's nothing.
Hank: It's a bison.
It's a bison.
There it is.
So, bye.
It was nice to meet you.